hello I'm Greg and I'm Kaila man Tyler
men the Kyler men on Twitter and
Instagram one in wild episodes on
periscope actively working not sleeping
because he's working so much on the fan
theory YouTube channel it'll be coming
out very soon keep a lookout for that
hey Kyle
you've seen the little show called Game
of Thrones haven't you a live game is
room
well Emilia Clarke starring in this
movie called the voice from the stone or
voice from the phew oh she is beautiful
you know I heard that she won't she
won't do nudity anymore yeah no that's a
damn shame
damn shame because she has a great body
she really does I love how she won't do
nudity anymore I have the same show what
difference will it be nothing
already done it yeah this is requested
from Denzel Diaz what's up Denzel he's
diseased Denzel Washington's
illegitimate child from Columbia yep
some sexuality nudity me and the boy
[Music]
my son my name and I think this thing
cuz I'm not like yes I much what
completely was talk just a house with
again giving you
[Music]
why I assume it's his mother or exceeds
even reason such worse
yeah Jacob every want you here he has a
challenge champion he went
[Music]
[Music]
don't don't don't you dare ready so long
man you can change this man the voice
[Music]
oh for Melia Clark that got darker and
darker was a really good trailer cuz
that first it starts off or I'm like I
can't tell if this is a if this is a
horror movie yeah or one of those like
slow pretty British drama yeah exactly
oh he's a mute child that she's gonna
help him out and then it gets in a
full-blown hoarder territory all of a
sudden I love movies where characters
for the main characters is deteriorating
over the course of the film
oh yeah and that's exactly what movie
that she looks all well-kept together
and all tethered up and pretty and
everything it's really interesting
because they like set it up I'm sure
that's how it's going to feel in the
movie too they set it up to be this this
either inspiring drama or something bad
thing and then it's like wait wait what
wait what yeah what especially at the
end there with the place with me like he
was like he's gonna bury her alive or
suffer during the wall oh what's
happening is I do like the setup until
it is a little different that we
actually get to see the mom at the
beginning the nurse has the connection
with the mom and the nurse needs to kind
of be causing this whole haunting
scenario yeah because the mother soon
when she was giving her like approval to
Emilia Clarke at the beginning of the
movie like I want you to take care of
him and then if I'm really disturbed and
bothered which he died so then it look
like Mila Carter was in on this what
never how Harry got sick and yeah I'm
early on I thought that the kid was just
kind of like he had like a mental
disability like cuz they could go that
direction yeah Weasley and they chose to
not do that Emilia Clarke it's funny
this says nudity and stuff I'm curious
what they're gonna look like she were
going to see her naked at one point and
she's like in the woods or something
naked I'm not doing to be unless it's in
wood in the wood it's a movie and also
white period piece whorehouse yeah yeah
you know this kind of money like the
others I'm just gonna say that yeah the
others yeah and it seems to really play
on tension and suspense and building all
that I take it the moms really talking
to her or maybe they're going a little
bit crazy
or maybe the trailer makes it look one
way because they tend to do that and
maybe she's just humoring the boy
because it's the only way to break
through to him well she won't why she
put her here up against the wall and
then she know at that point she's given
she's given him or maybe she might be
going crazy too because she can't take
care of this boy who she really care so
desperately to help out with yeah but
obviously the I think it's the father of
the boy that Martin's playing is it on
it
yeah it's a bad guy I mean look at him
even if I met that dude in real life he
told me he's an actor I'd be like you're
clearly only playing bad people he just
looks like a bad person oh yeah it's
sort of like that movie with with
Harrison Ford and he's like it's like
under the sheets that's not it what lies
beneath thank you yeah so it's like that
movie what lies beneath with Harrison
Ford in that regard like maybe he'd like
spins or I have always movies he had
something he had something to do with
the mom's death oh yeah I'm sure yeah
yeah something he was on burying her in
the wall yeah it seemed pretty obvious
right I'm having a little spoiler film
out to think about it yeah and so she
probably in that moment maybe reliving
the memory of just dead white ah yeah
why we see that yeah or maybe he's the
one in the wall and he's whispering as
if he's doing her voice and he's
impersonating yeah yeah and drag yeah
split and it also is adding on this
element of suspense where you don't
really see the scary stuff that's going
on oh yeah no it lets your mind do all
the work which I love that class so and
there's some cliched stuff I mean it's
done countless movies where the
character is spending at the top of the
roof and is about looks like they're
about to jump off you know and then I'm
like so many horror films but then they
actually don't but it freaks out the
Adult Care I really honestly thought he
was gonna push her and then somehow
she's a ghost or something I was like no
he's really gonna do it you know that
might be clever if actually she does die
but we don't see that as the audience
and then they reveal later that she did
get pushed off the roof we write scripts
we write script and we're rewriting the
film before while it's in
post-production right now or maybe the
woman at the beginning was just in one
of the other nannies you know and wasn't
his actual mom and maybe this guy is
like a series of dads a serial killer
that's really cool idea
we had the serial killer boys a mute and
then he just kind of loses his son or
this is his way of killing what my pal
luring the man kills them and that
reason in the wall that might be it that
would be I might be another nanny in the
wall that she was here I think we just
ruined the movie I think we just spoiled
the whole film he shouldn't have come
here higher our prediction there's gotta
be a game of thrones joke where you make
uh yeah when she's up on the tower I
wish she could just call her dragon yeah
because I'd be cool if the boy pushes
her off and she lands on a dragon we did
it we made a game of Thrones reference
we made a game of Thrones reference
everyone the videos complete shout out
to you guys subscriber the real reject
the Kyler men on Twitter and Instagram
whine and while in Paris cafe and on
youth tubba he is a starting up fan
theory where he makes theories based off
movies and [ __ ] off of being a fan
that's close but yeah that's it come on
after the title says write trickle you
gotta have a title that tells us what
the channel is all about it's accurate
like the real rejects like we're into
film but we don't know what we're
talking about Landing know that means
that's what this channel mean